we've been testing the new M3 M3 Pro and
M3 Max MacBook Pros tirelessly for the
past couple of weeks and if there's one
thing we've learned the M3 Ultra Max
studio is going to be absolutely insane
because the M3 Max has been
outperforming my own expectations which
were already very high so in this video
I'm going to talk about three things my
personal thoughts on how good the M3 Max
is and what surprised me especially
after we just did the massive M1 Max
versus M2 Max versus M3 Max performance
comparison video as well as the thermal
throttling video with the 14in where we
showed you the massive difference in
cooling systems so definitely watch
those two videos if you haven't already
after this one is over but the second
part of this video is going to be about
the leaks rumors and my predictions on
what exactly the M3 alra chip will look
like in terms of the specs and
performance including two potential
routes Apple could take with the chip
and the third thing is going to be my
analysis and predictions for the release
date and of course the price now before
we get into the new leaks let me first
start with my thoughts on the M3 Max
MacBook Pros holy moly guys if you
haven't seen those testing videos
definitely watch them because the full
16 core M3 Max is extremely impressive
we got a big jump in terms of the single
core performance about 17 1 12% higher
than M2 Max about 49% faster in
multicore which is just insane another
huge jump in gaming performance xcode
programming performance is absolutely
insane only 79 seconds logic pro running
328 tracks cinebench got a huge jump
photo editing took only 30 seconds and
especially rate tracing and blender 3D
rendering over twice as fast as the M2
Max but one thing we clearly know is
that Apple put everything they had into
this M3 Max chip they simply went all
out with those 12 performance cores
running at high clock speeds so what
this says to me is that we can expect
the M3 Ultra to be an absolute Beast
going into the Mac Studio and Mac Pro
because if this thin MacBook Pro laptop
handled all of that heat the Mac Studio
should be just fine when we tested the
M2 ultrax Studio we couldn't even get
the fans to spin up because the copper
cooling system was just so efficient and
the M2 Ultra still wasn't powerful
enough to give off enough heat so this
is incredibly reassuring for the M3
Ultra chip so with that said what should
we expect out of the M3 Ultra specs and
performance well getting into part
number two let's start off with some
thoughts from our German's most recent
power on newsletter where he discussed
the M3 Ultra but first I've got to show
you the best gift for your loved ones
this holiday season the ridge wallet
it's the thinnest wallet I could find
that can hold all of my cards up to 12
plus room for cash with over 30 plus
durable colors and styles all with RFID
blocking materials and a lifetime
guarantee you can even get 30% off your
order if you buy a matching key case
which holds up to six keys to keep them
from jingling so shop the holiday sale
by going to ridge.com maxtec and get up
to 30% off through December 20th and use
my links so you can enter free for a
chance to win a rid bundle worth
$44,000 thanks Ridge for sponsoring the
channel he believes that the M3 Ultra
could have a whopping 80 GPU cores 32
CPU cores and 256 gigs of unified memory
which assumes that Apple will continue
to combine two Max chip dieses into one
using their Ultra Fusion technology so
it's basically double everything that we
had with the M3 Max now the only problem
is that this year Apple for some reason
made a brand new design for the M3 Pro
chip instead of it being a cutdown
version of the M3 Max die this could
potentially mean that Apple might not
actually double the M3 Max dieses for
the ultra and maybe create a brand new
unique design instead but I don't
believe that's going to happen because
the entire point of combining two
smaller chips is to save money on the
Silicon compared to making megalithic
dyes which are very inefficient
and cost more money to manufacture and
second if we analyze the M3 Max die
we'll notice how it continues to be
designed in a way that'll be a perfect
setup for combining two of the chips
together for example the new M3 Pro die
has the GPU course is tucked above at
the top of the chip surrounded by lpddr5
Channels with Thunderbolt channels on
the bottom so it'll be impossible to
combine two of them to create a larger
chip but looking at the M3 Max the lp
ddr5 Channel are on the sides just like
they were before and the SLC cache leads
all the way down to the bottom getting
cut off along with all of the GPU cores
being at the bottom with all of the
channels of Thunderbolt and everything
else at the top this means that Apple
can easily connect another M3 Max die at
the bottom to create the M3 Ultra and
all of the GPU blocks will be
centralized close to each other which is
great for having GPU scaling and yes
this means we'll have 32 CPU cores 80
GPU cores and 256 gigs of potential
memory making it essentially the most
powerful consumer chip ever made how
powerful well I'm personally expecting
at least 30,000 multi-core points and
geekbench 6 dramatically outperforming
the highest possible Intel and ryzen
Chip scores of 23,000 points and that's
using the craziest Ram out there and as
for the GPU performance if we use the
new C bench 2024 GPU test I'm predicting
a score of around
24,000 points which will be higher than
an RTX 390 TI and RTX 470 TI and RAW
graphics performance and the important
thing to understand is that those other
Nvidia gpus are massive dedicated gpus
that are bigger than the Mac Studio
itself in terms of overall volume and
the M3 Ultra is going to be this little
chip inside of the Mac Studio running at
only up to 66 watts of GPU power which
we know because the M3 Max GPU peaked at
33 watts in the test that we ran and now
let's finish off with the third part of
the video which is the release date and
the price a lot of people are expecting
the M3 Ultra to come out this spring
during Apple's usual spring event but I
honestly don't think that's going to
happen I feel like it's going to get
delayed until
WWDC in June for two big reasons one the
MacBook Air still hasn't gotten updated
to the M3 chip even though all of the
MacBook Pros have so in my opinion this
absolutely must happen in the spring of
next year which means that it makes
sense to give the airs and the new M3
MacBook Pros more breathing room to sell
more stock for longer and for reason
number two we also have the Apple Vision
Pro headset which is likely coming in
the spring of next year so once again
they need more time for more attention
and headlines from the media so it makes
sense to delay the M3 Ultra until WWDC
in June and as for the price I'm
personally expecting the M3 Ultra Max
studio to stick to the same $4,000 base
price as we have right now however I
believe that the base model will be
double Bend which means that both of the
M3 Max dies inside of it will be the 14
core CPU and 38 core GPU versions so the
base M3 Ultra will likely only come with
a 28 core CPU and 76 core GPU but with
that said the M3 ultrax studio is likely
coming next summer in my opinion with a
$4,000 starting price so let me know
your thoughts down in the comment
section below and if you enjoy this
video subscribe above for more videos
like this one and check out one of those
two right there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next
[Music]
video